la ferme c'est à la fois un milieu de
travail et un milieu de vie où les
adultes et aussi les enfants sont
exposés à de nombreux dangers et ce au
quotidien
alors comment transmettre la passion de
l'agriculture aux jeunes tout en les
tenant à l'abri des dangers que la
machinerie où les animaux peuvent
représenter
[Musique]
moi j'avais trois et demi j'ai tombé sur
le dos plat drake de repenser si la roue
je me rappelle que de mon accident à
valence et c'est quand qu'on a entendu
le cri de mort
[Musique]
les deux enfants que je vois qu'ils ont
les amputations de membres sexuellement
des enfants qui viennent du milieu
agricole fait un kilomètre à sherbrooke
puis vous êtes sur une terre agricole
on est vraiment aux premières loges pour
s'intéresser à ce phénomène là des
accidents des enfants sur les fermes
parce que on a beaucoup de ces victimes
là dans nos éditions intensifs
le docteur claude cyr est pédiatre aux
soins intensifs du centre hospitalier
universitaire de sherbrooke
chaque jour il reçoit des jeunes
estropiés
mais dès que la belle saison arrive les
blessures de ses patients ont tendance à
s'aggraver
chaque été on voyait de trois enfants
qui était ami avec des blessures à la
fois fréquentes mais des blessures une
écho aux enfants sur les fermes les
amputations par exemple on s'est dit il
faut faire quelque chose quand on a ce
genre de phénomène lot des accidents
répétition la première étape c'est de
réfléchir à pourquoi sarr et le
cliniciens chercheurs décident alors
d'éplucher les rapports de coroners
s'étalant sur une période de 14 ans on
ne regardait de 2002 à 2015 tous les
décès d'enfants de moins de 18 ans donc
de 0 à 17 ans on ne regarde où est-ce
que ça s'était passé dans quel endroit
dans la ferme ça s'est passé mais aussi
les mécanismes qui ont mené à ces décès
là pour comprendre comment on peut faire
pour les prévenir
en parcourant ces rapports le pédiatre
réalise qu'il ya une cause commune à
tous ces accidents graves et des décès
d'enfants survenus sur les fermes du
québec
[Musique]
je voudrais un point fondamental c'est
que la majorité des décès des enfants
québécois sur une ferme surviennent
après un contact avec de la machinerie
agricole donc majoritairement avec des
tracteurs
[Musique]
sébastien gaudreault est propriétaire
d'une ferme de céréales biologiques à st
henri de taillon lac saint jean avec sa
conjointe et leurs enfants il vit son
rêve
j'adorais les machineries agricoles
j'adorais la tête quand je voyais les en
alberto ce qui se faisait les grandes
perles et les grandes cultures les
moissonneuses batteuses j'ai toujours un
morceau alors qu'il n'a peine que quatre
ans sébastien supplie son père de le
laisser monter avec lui sur son tracteur
celle la journée d'anniversaire de ma
mère en septembre j'ai complètement
oublié de me tenir de 2,2 reste en
position je tombais mon père cm2
m'agripper mais ça n'a pas fonctionné
c'est l'usagé de mes jambes que j'ai pu
en raison de cet accident à l'eau
malgré son handicap l'agriculteur n'a
jamais remis en question son choix de
vivre et de travailler sur une ferme et
surtout d'opérer de la machinerie
agricole jamais peu de rab arqués sur un
tracteur puis mon père mes parents m'ont
toujours le sofa à 12 ans j'avais déjà
des tâches mon père venait meeddat
descendre du tracteur pays mais c'était
comme ça j'ai toujours aimé ça dans son
étude claude cyr a non seulement
colliger les données du bureau du
coroner
mais également celle de l'institut de
santé publique du québec
il constate qu'en cuisant 284 jeunes
d'âge mineur ont subi des traumatismes
graves sur les fermes familiales au
québec c'est plus d'une vingtaine en
moyenne par année
17 enfants en sont décédées les enfants
qui sont victimes d'accidents sur les
fermes ont souvent des blessures plus
sévère
plus grave je vous parlais des
amputations tantôt mais beaucoup
d'enfants peuvent rester paraître léger
parce qu'ils ont des lésions au niveau
de la colonne vertébrale
beaucoup d'enfants ont des traumas
crâniens parce qu'ils vont avoir des
accidents de véhicules hors route
d'autres études viennent confirmer les
observations du docteur cyr
l'association canadienne de sécurité
agricole indique qu en nombre absolu de
décès il n'existe pas d'occupation plus
dangereuse que l'agriculture est du côté
de la santé publique on se préoccupait
déjà en 2011 du taux élevé
d'hospitalisations et de décès chez les
très jeunes enfants ceux âgés de 1 à 4
ans qui vivent sur les fermes des
cheveux d'un enfant qui prennent dans
une tige mécanique une tige rotative
avec l'enfant qui va décéder un enfant
écrasé par un chariot nourrisseur
motorisés frappé par un tracteur qui
recule donc je pourrais continuer ce
sont tous des exemples de d'enfants de
moins de 5 ans qui sont décédés sur le
rush sur les fermes au québec dans les
dernières scènes
[Musique]
j'ai aucun son n'est vraiment quand
j'étais jeune 2
un accident
nous sommes à la ferme laitière de la
famille lavigne ste-anne-de-prescott
près de hawkesbury en ontario avec trois
cent cinquante vaches dont 165 en
lactation le travail ici ne manquent pas
ça m'empêche
flavien avait deux ans et demi quand le
drame est survenu
sa mère elle s'en souvient trop bien moi
je faisais la tête de l'après midi avec
un employé mon conjoint et mon beau père
travaille adore la déplacer là de la
machinerie
on lève n'est pas à l'extérieur d'europe
step c'est trop dangereux que les
machines ça fait qu'on dit on va le
cedar grande il y avait un grillage un
gros ventilateur melli tout à fait pour
la météo en nature ici c'est celle où
c'est arrivé
le pire allait survenir flavier y aller
c'est un avant bras
c'était difficile moi je n'avais jamais
un stress c'est certain que la première
journée ou deux je peux dire le travail
à la ferme était limité à l'essentiel
mais je pense côté master plus le tout
ce qui est psychologique autour de solo
qui est plus difficile j'étais enceinte
d'une petite fille aussi en même temps
que j'ai perdu quelques mots plus tard
dans son étude le docteur claude cyr
s'est attardé aux recommandations des
coronaires il a réalisé que beaucoup de
travail reste à faire en matière de
prévention et d'éducation les coroners
qui à chaque fois qu'un décès accidentel
font un rapport assez exhaustif des des
circonstances du décès des causes du
décès mais surtout roman de façon très
importante sur les moyens pour prévenir
et souvent on parle de moyens simples où
il ne suffirait que d'appliquer la
réglementation existante notamment celle
de l'âge légal pour conduire un tracteur
de ferme ou un vtt en milieu agricole
nous regarder les recommandations sur
l'âge minimal pour faire certaines
tâches sur les fermes et pour quelles
sont les étapes pour pouvoir utiliser la
machinerie
donc si on avait appliqué ces
recommandations là on estime que 70 %
des décès auraient pu être prévenues
puis presque 80% des blessures auraient
pu être prévenues
on a des enfants aussi jeunes que cette
qui conduisait détracteurs puis qui ont
écrasé leur frère de 5 ans donc au lieu
de dire soyez prudents sur la ferme on
peut être plus spécifique en disant par
exemple il faut séparer les enfants
détracteurs deuxièmement il faut pas
qu'un enfant d'un scolaire ou d'âge
préscolaire utilisent les arts de
travail comme aire de jeu quand on
travaille avec nos enfants
vous savez que des fois là on travaille
mais on n'est pas tout la sela des fois
que le petit avant votre cette manette
qui va y arriver quelque chose
ébranlé par ce constat l'union des
producteurs agricoles a mis en place des
ateliers pour sensibiliser ses membres
sur les dangers qui guettent les enfants
à la ferme
ouellette gilbert et la responsable
régionale du programme de prévention
sécurisé jour et du pea
on entendait portement dans une état
savait déjà qu'on les perde de vue de
cinq minutes c'est là qu'arrive un
accident et sur la ferme les dangers
cachés en a partout ça faisait votre
maxime peu comme quand après non non
parce que j'aime ça sébastien gaudreault
participent à ces ateliers
il a été recruté par l'ipea pour venir
raconter son histoire et sensibiliser
les enfants qui vivent en milieu rural
déjà la personne en danger est ce que tu
es voir des jeunes ben ils font un peu
le saut quand ils voient première fois
mais le message est beaucoup plus
frappant parce que l'eau ils peuvent
constater vraiment là qu'est ce qui peut
arriver mais jusqu'où ça peut aller
[Musique]
depuis l'accident de leur fils jean
pierre et sa conjointe chanas ont
poursuivi l'expansion de leurs fermes
la sécurité était bien sûr au centre de
leurs préoccupations
les peaux sèches unis sont mieux clôture
et derrière on a mis un échelle avec des
barreaux puis des passerelles pour
monter en haut on peut avoir des fermes
plus sécuritaire mais le risque zéro
n'existe pas sur les faits
on se trouve bel équilibre entre les
deux les figures des soit plus
sécuritaire possible géante côté cité
les amène pas la ferme qu'ils sont
jeunes minces
souvent ils reprendront pour la relève
c'est un modèle low ses robes
travaillées soit que ça j'aimerais bien
travailler comme
sont les machines
[Musique]
faut pas oublier qu'au québec quand même
le la majorité des fermes ça demain des
fermes familiales de génération en
génération
et puis moi je trouve que c'est bien
comme ça ça serait souhaitable que ça
reste comme ça aussi
donc en sachant ça c'est très difficile
de dire aux parents
il faut que les enfants et de contacts
du tout avec les avec les tracteurs
moment d'inattention un accident dit
quand on arrive au poste un grand mot
mais prévenir et de souvent c'est guéri
au québec lui paie acp s'est associé à
la commission de la santé sécurité au
travail pour sensibiliser les familles
d'agriculteurs et planche actuellement
sur un programme de services de garde
destinée aux réalités du milieu agricole
on dit souvent ça prend un village pour
élever un enfant le message ça prend
vraiment un village pour ses succès sur
et de la sécurité de nos enfants au
québec
qu'est ce que tu aimes le plus du
travail ou la liées à la sphère toi
[Musique]
ce que tu aimes le moins
gratuit
c'est sympa
[Musique]